what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thorns season a
discussion video today I want to talk
about one of the most mysterious aspects
of this story which are the others
also known as the knight King and the
White Walkers they are very important to
this overall story yet we know very
little about them or their motives even
after several books have been published
and with only one season left of the
television series we still don't have
many answers regarding to who the knight
King really is and what he actually
wants what makes this a little bit more
difficult to discuss is the fact that
the knight king in the show is different
than the night's king from the books but
since the show version is based off the
books I will use all the evidence at my
disposal this is one part of the story
that has always fascinated me and trying
to figure this out as like trying to
crack the da Vinci Code because there
isn't much evidence to go on the others
are only encountered a few times in the
books one time during the prologue in a
game of Thrones then at the Battle of
the fist of the first men and Sam kills
one with an obsidian dagger thanks to
the television show we have seen much
more in we learned a hell of a lot more
which still isn't much but it isn't
clear if anything we learned about them
from the show is gonna be book canon or
not I will be the first one to say I
don't have all the answers I don't think
anyone does besides george RR martin and
maybe Dan and Dave but I love to
speculate about this topic and I know
there are some very convincing theories
already out there now when it comes to
the television show the answer might be
a little more straightforward than what
it is in the books
but first let's go over what we do know
or at least what we have been told thus
far according to legend the others came
for the first time from the lands of
always winter around 8,000 years ago the
others were said to be tall and fast in
phenomenal swordsmen wielding
razor-sharp swords made of ice or
crystal that can cut through chainmail
like its silk when the others came from
the lands of always winter they brought
with them the cold and darkness that
lasted an entire generation also known
as the long night and when they came
south they had resurrected dead men and
animals fighting along with them just
like old nan said during
four tails this was a winter that lasted
an entire generation where some people
were born and lived and died and only
knew the icy cold darkness but then
there was a battle for the dawn there
was a great war just like we may see
again in season eight
but around 8,000 years ago during the
battle for the dawn finally someone
emerged who could put a stop to this
endless night the last hero along with
12 companions set out into the darkness
to find the children of the forest
according to legend this mission lasted
four years and while they sought out the
chosen are the forest all of the last
heroes companions started to disappear
it's assumed that they most likely died
but no one really knows for sure but
finally the last hero found the children
of the forest and what their help the
Nights Watch was formed and the war was
ended the others fled to the lands of
always winter and brained in the builder
constructed the wall of ice using giants
and possibly even magic from the
children of the forest the only problem
I have with this story is no one really
knows how this war ended all we really
know is winter that lasted a generation
finally stopped and the others weren't
seen or heard from again for quite some
time
we know the White Walkers in the night
King wasn't completely exterminated
because the others are back again and
they are pissed off for some reason so
the big question is what was the last
hero finally able to do that caused them
to lay dormant for so many years there
must have been some kind of deal made a
peace treaty to end the war but the
terms of this pact aren't exactly clear
either the fighting obviously stopped
and the wall was built to keep the
others out in case something ever
happened again but now that they are
back something must have happened to
cause them to want to come south again I
was thinking the answer might lie with
the Nights Watch itself because I
remember old nan once told brand that
monsters cannot pass through the wall as
long as the man of the Nights Watch
stayed true so I was thinking what could
have initially started all of this as I
was reading some information about the
Nights Watch and all the former Lord
commanders of the Nights Watch I
realized there is no record of the first
12 Lord commanders of the Nights Watch
which I did think was kind of strange
you
would think the very first Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch would be
someone pretty famous or at least his
name would be on record somewhere but
it's not the first time we hear about a
Lord Commander on the wall was when we
learn about the 13th Lord Commander of
the Nights Watch who interestingly
enough is the night's king himself now
it's not the same night king from the
television show but he is a night's king
nonetheless so then I started thinking
how come the first time we hear about a
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch isn't
until the night's king is ruling the
wall the night's king also lived during
the Age of Heroes not long after the
wall was built all we really know about
him is he ended up falling in love with
the woman whose skin was as cold as ice
and his white is the moon and she had
eyes like blue stars and when he gave
her his seed he gave her his soul as
well and this is when he brought her
back to the Nightfort and made her his
queen
and together they rolled on the wall for
thirteen years he was able to bound the
Nights Watch to as well and he was even
making sacrifices to the others that's
until the king in the north brained in
the breaker and the king-beyond-the-wall
Jorah men banded together to bring them
down and free the Nights Watch after the
13th Lord Commander was defeated all
records of him were destroyed and it was
forbidden to speak of the night's king
after this but what about the twelve
Lord commanders who came before him why
is there no record of them also as I was
thinking about this I suddenly
remembered one scene from the show that
kind of blew my mind for a second when I
thought about it and this could be
nothing but it could be something also
but if you go to the scene when we see
the night King for the first time it's
during this sacrifice of crest or Sun
this is when the white Walker places the
baby on the altar made of ice and the
night King comes forward to turn the
baby into a white Walker but if you look
behind the night King there is 12 men
standing there and I started to wonder
could they be the first 12 Lord
commanders of the Nights Watch that
aren't on record anywhere the night's
king is on record being the 13th Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch so maybe
those 12 men behind him are the first 12
Lord commanders of the Nights Watch but
those 12 men standing behind the night
game could also be someone else
when the last hero went looking for the
children of the forest who in the long
night he took 12 companions with them
and those 12 companions went missing no
one knows exactly what happened to those
12 men everyone just assumed that they
died but maybe they are still on duty
just in another way and this brings me
back to how the last hero was actually
able to defeat the others in the first
place how would he have been able to do
this basically on his own the last hero
had to have made some kind of deal with
the children or the forest and the
others to end the war that's when I
started thinking what if the last hero
actually turned rogue and he offered the
others a marriage Alliance and he
promised to give them sacrifices so that
the others could grow their army again
as long as they would let him live just
like Craster did this would certainly
get the others to stop fighting for the
time being and this would also play into
George RR Martin's idea of making
characters and his story good and bad
there is no way George would make a
character like the last hero who only
does good that would go against what he
said he wanted to do with his story so
this is when the wall was built to
separate the territories in the last
hero could have volunteered to stay at
the wall and guarded himself but deep
down he knows he has to keep his end on
the bargain with the others and that's
when one day the female other shows up
and this is when he keeps his end of the
deal so he marries her and gives her his
seed and his soul and together they
start making babies and giving them up
to the others this is when he becomes
the night's king the thirteenth Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch but
everyone south of the wall has no idea
about this part of the deal that he made
until they found out what he is doing at
the wall and this is one brand in the
breaker and joram and team up to put a
stop to this which could cut the others
off from getting their sacrifices once
the night's king is defeated at the wall
the others basically lie in wait until
someone else comes along to make
sacrifices for them again and keep their
end of the deal they did an attack for
all these years because their army
wasn't big enough and they didn't have a
way to bring down the wall anyway so you
fast forward many years later and now
you have crashed her sacrificing his
kids and the others slowly start growing
their numbers again that's until Craster
is killed and the others no longer
get their sacrifices that they were
promised to them since the original deal
was made with the last hero now the
night king is pissed and he sees this as
an outright act of war but he still
couldn't kill everyone obviously because
everyone fled from north of the wall
that was until he got his hands on the
dragon now of course this is a little
bit different from the show because the
show version has the night king being
created by the children of the forest
and Dan and Dave give a very
straightforward description other night
king Dan and Dave said they don't think
of the night king as the villain as much
as death he is not someone who's like
Geoffrey or Ramsey he's not really human
anymore
evil comes when you have a choice
between that and good and you don't
choose the wrong way the night king
doesn't have a choice he was created in
that way and that's what he is in some
ways he's just death coming for everyone
in the story and for all of us in some
ways it's appropriate he doesn't speak
what's death going to say anything would
diminish him he's just a force of
destruction I don't think we've even
ever attempted to write dialogue for the
night King anything he said would be
anticlimactic that's what the showrunner
said during an interview so it seems
like their version is cut and dry but
maybe their description is some
misdirection but what do you all think
his motives are what is your answer for
why the night king has become active
again and seemingly on a mission to
destroy everything that we know
I am hoping there is a deeper meaning
for all of this because I would prefer
the answer to be something clever when
we find out the night Kings true
intentions personally I just think it is
very strange there is no record of the
first 12 Lord commanders of the Nights
Watch
and that's the same number of men the
last he were had in his party when he
sought out the children of the forest
and ultimately ended the war somehow
with the others then we see this image
of the night king in the show for the
first time and he has 12 men standing
behind him during the first sacrifice we
get to see there seems to be some kind
of connection there in the timeline
during the long night isn't exactly
clear so in my opinion I think it is
very plausible the last year who made a
deal with the others and his part of the
deal was through a marriage alliance
with the Knights Queen and together they
would make sacrifices to the others so
that they
continued their own bloodline as I was
researching some of this I did notice
some older posts through Google where
people also made some connections with
the night's king in the last hero but
the ones I saw they think the others
actually may have built the wall
themselves to keep the humans out of
their lands and that was the original
deal that they made which does make some
sense considering the wall is made of
ice and George did say the others can
manipulate ice in magical ways but that
wouldn't explain why the others would
make a wall with magical spells to keep
themselves out so I'm not so sure about
that but it was very interesting and
exciting to know I wasn't the only one
who thought the last tier were when the
night's king could be one in the same
but just let me know what you think down
below why do you think the night king is
on a path of death and destruction and
do you think there was some kind of an
ancient pact made that was broken which
caused the night King to react or do you
think the night king is just some evil
force looking to extinguish life as we
know it put your thoughts questions and
comments down below I want to thank you
all for stopping by and watching today's
video I really appreciate that and I had
to bank all my new patreon supporters
too I hope everyone has a great day I'll
see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]